AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
OVER THE WEEKEND, SOME IN THE
PARTY PUSH FOR IMPEACHMENT AND
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI URGES
CAUTION.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT REALLY
WORRIED.
>> YOU ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
BEING PROSECUTED ONCE YOU LEAVE
OFFICE?
>> I DID NOTHING WRONG, GEORGE.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
YOU DON'T EVEN HEAR RUSSIA
MENTIONED ANYMORE.
RUSSIA IS NOT MENTIONED.
NOW IT'S ABOUT OBSTRUCTION OF
WHAT?
THEY HIRED A MAN WHO HATED TRUMP
AND HE HIRED 18 PEOPLE THAT WERE
DEMOCRATS THAT HATED TRUMP.
SOME OF THEM CONTRIBUTED TO
CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN.
>> PELOSI HOLDING FIRM AND NOT
WANTING TO RUSH INTO IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANYTHING MORE DIVISIVE WE CAN DO
KNOW THAT TO IMPEACH A PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE TO HANDLE IT WITH GREAT
CARE.
IT HAS TO BE ABOUT THE TRUTH AND
THE FACTS TO TAKE YOU TO
WHATEVER DECISION HAS TO BE
THERE.
IT SHOULD BY NO MEANS BE DONE
POLITICALLY.
>> AND THE FRESHMAN
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ AIRING GRIEVANCES
ABOUT NANCY PELOSI'S REFUSAL TO
IMPEACH TRUMP.
>> NANCY PELOSI HAS SAID SO FAR
SHE IS NOT READY TO DO THAT.
>> IT'S QUITE REAL.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A VERY REAL
DESIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE -- THAT WE ARE HOLDING THIS
PRESIDENT TO ACCOUNT.
>> JUAN, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
HOW ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ,
SHE IS FROM A VERY BLUE DISTRICT
AND DOESN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
HER OWN RE-ELECTION.
SHE IS SETTING DOWN THE MARKER
THAT THE PROGRESSIVE WING WON'T
WORRY ABOUT THE OTHER DISTRICTS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SEE THE
PRESIDENT HELD TO ACCOUNT.
>> BUT THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN IMPEACHING PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND REMOVING HIM FROM
OFFICE.
WHEN I HEAR ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ SPEAK, IT'S OUT OF
A FURY AT TRUMP.
IT REPRESENTS CLOSE TO 70% OF
THE DEMOCRATIC BASE THAT WANTS
HIM IMPEACHED.
BUT THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN IMPEACHMENT AND HAVING
THE SENATE CONVICT THE PRESIDENT
AND REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE.
IT'S A MATTER OF UNDERSTANDING.
NANCY PELOSI IS FOCUSSED ON
2020.
NOT ONLY ON KEEPING CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE AND RETAINING HER
SPEAKERSHIP BUT ON DEFEATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND LOOKS AT THE DISTRICTS YOU
HIGHLIGHTED OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS AND SAID A LOT OF THESE
DEMOCRATS WHO WON IN 2018 IN THE
MID-TERMS WERE PEOPLE WHO CAME
FROM WHAT I WOULD CALL PURPLE,
MAYBE EVEN REDDISH DISTRICTS.
PELOSI IS A SMART POLITICAL
PLAYER.
>> PELOSI HAS MORE OF A HOLD ON
HER CAUCUS.
>> I KNOW.
>> IF THE PROGRESSIVES MADE
THEIR OWN CAUCUS COULD THERE BE
MORE PROBLEMS FOR HER?
>> THERE COULD BE, BUT SHE'S NOT
GOING TO IMPEACH BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE VOTES.
61% OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
WANT IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S IN THE CUE POLL.
THEY ARE MISREADING THE PUBLIC.
THEY HAD IMPEACHMENT RALLIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY OVER THE
WEEKEND.
A TOTAL BUST.
NO ONE REALLY SHOWED UP.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> EXACTLY!
>> AND YOU ARE IN THE BUSINESS.
THE WHOLE NEWS CYCLE IS DRIVEN
BY IMPEACHMENT THROUGH THE
PRESS.
THE PRESS WANTS TO BOOK
DEMOCRATS WHO WANT TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY INVITE THEM ON AND DO A
SEGMENT.
THEN THE MEDIA RUNS A POLL AND
DO A SEGMENT ON THE POLL AND
THEY AND DONALD TRUMP ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
THEN THEY DO A SEGMENT.
IT'S A SELF-PERPETUATE
IT'S A SELF-PERPETUAING NEWS
CYCLE.
CNN AND MSNBC'S RATINGS ARE
GOING DOWN.
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY SI AM
GOING TO GET A BEER ON THE
PORCH.
I DON'T CARE ANYMORE.
>> DID YOU GET A BEER ON THE
PORCH THIS WEEKEND?
>> I WISH!
THE SMALL PICTURE AND THEN I
WILL MOVE ON TO THE BIG PICTURE.
THE SMALL PICTURE BEGINS WITH
THIS.
DID YOU EVER GET IN A FIGHT WITH
YOUR SPOUSE FOR LITTLE OR NO
REASON WHY?
WHY DO YOU DO THAT?
BECAUSE YOU CAN.
BOTH OF OFF ARE HEALTHY AND THE
FINANCES ARE OKAY.
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO BICKER.
TRUST ME, WHEN ONE PERSON IS ILL
OR ANOTHER PERSON IS IN
FINANCIAL PERIL THERE IS NO
BICKERING.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE HAVE A HUGE
CONCERN.
THE BIG PICTURE:
WE ARE LIVING IN AN AMAZING
TIME.
WE HAVE TO BROADEN THE
DEFINITION OF NEWS TO INCLUDE
STUFF THAT IS NOT REAL NEWS.
PEOPLE ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT
STUFF THAT MAY HAPPEN, NOT IS
HAPPENING.
THERE IS NO IMPEACHMENT.
THESE ARE WHAT IF ARGUMENTS AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT ARE ARGUMENTS.
WE HAD THIS SHIFT TO WHAT IF
ARGUMENTS OVER THE LAST 2 YEARS.
IN THE PAST THE ISSUES, WHAT ARE
WAR, TERROR, POVERTY,
UNEMPLOYMENT AND CRIME.
THEY STILL EXIST BUT YOU CAN'T
DENY THE DIRECTION THE WORLD IS
GOING IN, IN SOLVING A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES.
ISIS, NORTH KOREA AND
JOBLESSNESS.
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT TAINTED
ALCOHOL IN THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC.
AMERICA IN 2019 ARE LIKE MICHAEL
JORDAN IN 1990 SUFFERING FROM A
HANGNAIL.
>> WE ARE HEADING INTO THE
ROARING 2020s.
>> WILL KID ARE PLAYING IN THE
BACK YARD BECAUSE MOMMY AND
DADDY BUILT THEM A NICE SAFE
HOME WITH A GREAT SAND BOX AND
SWING SET.
MOMMY AND DADDY ARE TRUMP'S
AMERICA.
THE KIDS ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
CRIME, KIDNAPPING OR WAGES
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING UP.
THEY PLAY ALL DAY IN THE
IMPEACHMENT BACKYARD.
>> ONE OF THE POLLS SAID THAT A
TOTAL OF 27% OF PEOPLE WANT TO
SEE IMPEACHMENT.
I SAW A NEWS REPORT LAST NIGHT,
NOT ON OUR NETWORK, WOW, THIS IS
REALLY GROWING!
IT'S 27% OF THE COUNTRY.
>> AND 3% MARGIN OF ERROR.
IT COULD BE AS LOW AS 24%.
EVERYONE MADE SUCH GOOD POINTS.
>> EVEN JUAN?
>> YES.
>> I WILL START WITH YOU, JUAN.
THE POINT YOU MADE THAT IS
EXCELLENT.
WHERE DOES THE FURY STOP FOR THE
DEMOCRATS THAT SHOUT ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT THAT DOESN'T EQUAL
REMOVAL?
.
WE KNOW FROM THE MUELLER REPORT,
THERE WILL BE ANOTHER ONE.
IT'S ALWAYS A STEP FURTHER.
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT AOC'S
DELUSION, SHE HONESTLY BELIEVES
THAT THEY RISK LOSING THE
PRESIDENCY THE NEXT ONE UNLESS
THEY ELECT A CANDIDATE THAT
BELIEVES FROM TRUE
TRANSFORMATIONAL QUALITIES FOR
EVERY AMERICAN.
I DROVE AROUND SIX STATES AND
TEXAS WITH THE FOX.
>> 6 DATES?
>> 6 STATES.
THIS IS A FAMILY SHOW.
THAT'S NOT WHAT PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
IT SPEAKS TO THE LEVEL OF THE
16-YEAR-OLD TEENAGER HAVING THE
LOUDEST VOICE.
THE POLL SAID THAT 40% EVER
INDEPENDENTS SUPPORT
IMPEACHMENT.
>> YOU ONLY TALKED ABOUT HIS
POINT AND NOT ANYBODY ELSE'S.
>> LET ME SAY THAT IT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO AGREED WITH
HER WHICH WAS A SURPRISE.
>> I TOLD YOU.
THEY ARE LIKE TWO PEAS IN A POD.
IN A ROOM THEY WOULD BE FAST